a hearty congratulations to our next
guest because his book that we've been
talking about um is finally out where
all books are sold it's called
playmakers
how the nfl really works and doesn't
mike florio of pro football talk right
here on the rich eisen show mercedes
benz vans phone line how are you mike
i'm doing great rich how are you today
thank you so much for having me of
course congrats how's the book tour
doing so far well
when
i
advocated with the publisher
to release the book during the week of
free agency because that's our busiest
time of the year
and we can sell the most books and it
makes sense let's sell a football book
when it's not football season because in
football season who cares they're
watching football so it all made sense
to have this book out there
our busiest week of the year and then it
dawned on me yesterday this is our
busiest week of the year this is not the
ideal time to be trying to sell a book
on top of everything else we're doing so
a lot of caffeine has been consumed this
week and uh we just get through it and
i'm glad to be
on your show as part of this media tour
because we're doing like 30 of them this
week but it's great because you just
pick up the phone or you go log on to
your laptop and you click the zoom
button i think it's uh uh a a great
thing to write a book and uh have it on
a shelf forevermore the proverbial no
one can ever take it away from you
although i don't know whose ever tries
to take something from somebody in the
history of this cliche they can never
take away the thing that they wouldn't
want
right so again congratulations on that
playmakers where all books can be
acquired um and so let's let's jump into
baker mayfield right here
and you know the browns have every right
to upgrade their position mayfield has
every right to say what gives um his
play in year four did not merit a
long-term deal uh one is not coming and
instead the team is talking to desean
watson how real is it
that watson might be going or thinking
about cleveland well i don't know
about what watson wants and this really
is set up for watson to be able to pick
which team he wants there were multiple
reports last night which tell me someone
wanted this out there that before anyone
could sit down with watson rich they had
to be basically pre-approved by the
texans as it relates to the trade
package that would have been given or
will be given to houston for watson
which allows watson to now just say
here's where i want to go and there's
nothing to be done the trade is in hand
and you go forward so it's going to come
down to how he feels about the saints
panthers browns falcons where he wants
to go out of those four teams i don't
know i kind of like the idea of the
browns but at the same time i don't like
the idea of the afc or the afc north so
it's really going to come down to where
he's comfortable and where he wants to
go
but i think that the bigger issue here
because at first i thought wow this is
gutsy at the browns to go all in for
watson because if they don't get him
they got a problem with baker mayfield
i've reached the point now where i
conclude that
this is the first step toward the
divorce from baker mayfield that the
real message is they've decided to move
on because for a guy like mayfield you
can't even start down this path unless
you're ready to finish and i think
they're ready to to say
baker's out and we're going in another
direction and if it's desean watson
great and if it's not that's fine too
we're going to find somebody other than
baker mayfield and it all comes down to
erratic play and contractual
expectations and if he would have a
great year in 2022 rich because every
other year he's good if he he's due for
a good year high level analytics every
other year he's good right like brett
saberhagen back in the day yeah right um
but but if if that happens
you get backed into a corner you gotta
give him 40 million a year and then
you're the rams after 2023 saying what
do we got to do to get rid of jared goff
so i think they're they're being very
smart about where this goes there's no
good way out of this if he's good this
year and you have to give him the
contract he wants you're constantly
worried when's he going to backslide so
let's just be done with it now let's rip
the band-aid off and let's move on and i
think that's what they're in the process
of doing and that's why mayfield is
sending out the um pre-emptive farewell
for a breakup that hasn't happened yet
you know and i heard you earlier i had a
flashback to
the first time i was ever on the air
with you it was me you and shefty in
tampa yeah
super bowl early 2009 we were talking
about donna mcnabb and i said the
mcnabb's play is i am breaking up with
you that's the move that mayfield may be
trying to do here the old that was the
advice that kramer gave to costanza
remember noelle and they had the pez
dispenser when she was doing her her
recital and she was upset about that it
was elaine's laugh because i am breaking
up with you
and that may be what mayfield's trying
to do because look i i think it's over
it's just a matter of time and it's
going to be fascinating to see where he
goes and who the browns end up with if
it's not desean watson well because then
mike florio here author of playmakers
and the pft
live host as well as profootballtalk.com
creator and owner and so the question is
i have for you sir is if
watson doesn't come you're saying that
the the browns are willing to put
themselves potentially in the category
of what the cults are in right now or
seattle
is in right now and willing to see with
amari cooper and his 20 million bucks
and whatever else they're going to put
together uh on this offense to see if
case keenum might go and do it right
which as you know stefanski knows
firsthand
uh is that the the brown's
way of of going into this lamar and boro
top-heavy division you think i think
keenum would be the fallback if they
can't find somebody between keenum and
watson and my guess is they've got a
plan you know how the browns are they
and john d podesta and you but we've got
a plan for everything and it's all
analytics and they're going to move from
this guy to this guy to this guy but
keenum and stefanski working together in
minnesota got to the brink of the super
bowl in 2017.
and you know the one thing that
i think is easy to lose sight of because
we're not privy to everything that goes
on behind the curtain but we've seen
enough in front of the curtain from
baker mayfield to come to the reasonable
conclusion that he may be a little bit
of a pain in the ass for the browns
right and they may have gotten to the
point where they've had enough
and there's been enough flashes of it
that we've seen over the past couple of
years and the browns try to be very
professional and keep it out of sight
but but you know and mayfield's got i i
like that aspect of his personality
there's a point where you got to turn it
off or you got to be so good that you
overcome that element of your overall
makeup like aaron rodgers is a pain in
the butt but he's he's good enough that
the packers are going to tolerate it
mayfield's not so good that the browns
are going to tolerate it so i'd go with
keenum
because kingdom's not going to give you
a problem and he's going to play at a
sufficiently high level and the offense
doesn't run through the quarterback
anyway it probably will if they get to
sean watson but they can just run the
ball and keenum can do his thing and
they'll see if they're competitive and
they keep looking for a quarterback if
that's their worst case scenario my
guess is they have plans
that you know go for i mean if keenum is
plan d
and watson is plan a we'll see what plan
b and plan c may be so just to put a
button on the the watson conversation
mike florio so the way this is working
is similar to
what uh buying a house or getting your
your mortgage
done is that you need pre-approval by
the bank and that's text the texans by
saying here is you need to apply let's
see on your application your your uh
compensation for us to trade you desean
watson
and then then or is watson the bank
saying that uh i will not uh grant you
this uh loan or this mortgage because i
don't want to come to you
are the texans and watson after all this
time finally working in concert that's
why i think they are and you know what i
love a good metaphor but this is
basically aaron rodgers without the
packers trying to conceal the notion
that a situation has been engineered
where the quarterback is picking
a team
that the packers allowed i believe his
agent david dunn
to set up
potential trades the terms are in place
the compensation is in place and all
aaron rodgers has to do is pick his next
team but the packers were one of the
options and that's the team he picked
for watson same approach we know about
it but the texans aren't on the menu
it's going to be one of these four teams
that we know about and whoever else may
come to the table but you know i know
there was talk yesterday of the 49ers in
play i don't think anybody else could
really be in play secretly there's too
many moving parts too many people have
to know about it for it to be kept a
secret so you have to be prepared if
you're going to make this play for
watson that people are going to know
about it and then i guess the legal
aspect of it is i mean didn't he have
depositions taken civilly yesterday i
mean
the minute that no criminal uh that that
no bill came back from the grand jury
last friday that that's all teams needed
to pretty much know they figure
everything else can be handled there's
no problem calculated risk there and
not getting indicted on nine criminal
complaints means only they didn't get
indicted it doesn't mean he didn't do it
it doesn't mean that he is free and
clear and faces no legal jeopardy in the
civil system there's 22 lawsuits that
have to be resolved he's either going to
have those cases settled maybe he gets a
dismissal of some of them he may have to
go to trial on some he could win he
could lose i don't know when the league
is going to take action the league has
learned in recent years that it's best
to wait until the last possible minute
to do anything
and maybe they defer action on watson's
situation until these civil cases are
over and really rich if he would if he
would take all 22 of them to trial and
win every one of them
and he didn't get indicted what does the
league do what can the league do at that
point is it a violation of the personal
conduct policy if you have been
aggressively pursued in both branches of
the justice system and prevailed in
every outcome i i don't know i don't
know we we may we may find out
eventually but i i think so i think
what's happened is and this has worked
very well to the benefit of the texans
and the watts and deshaun watson over
the weekend
this market kicked up and i think you've
got teams that are saying you know what
whatever the short-term pain is whatever
the pr hit may be whatever whatever we
may have to deal with in 2022
we're gonna have a franchise quarterback
for 10 years
and winning cures everything one of the
chapters in playmakers talks about how
quickly ben roethlisberger was redeemed
in pittsburgh by what by winning and i
think the teams that want watson are
betting that he's going to go there and
he's going to play so well that this is
all going to be forgotten i'm not saying
it's right or wrong but we've seen it
play out before mike florio here on the
rich eisen show what happened with randy
gregory and the cowboys
and the broncos on tuesday very simply
and i'll try to be as succinct as
possible monday night he was ready to do
a deal with the broncos the cowboys got
involved the cowboys talked him into
sticking around the cowboys were willing
to match
what the broncos were going to pay the
cowboys previously weren't going to go
that far but then came the contract and
there's language in every contract that
will result in future guaranteed money
being voided and for most teams if not
all teams but the cowboys it's tied to
being suspended the cowboys for every
player except act prescott will wipe out
future guarantees if you're simply fined
under the substance abuse policy that's
one of the examples and that's pertinent
for randy gregory because he's had
multiple substance abuse policy issues
so as it relates to gregory 28 million
guaranteed 14 million paid this year 14
million base salary next year fully
guaranteed
in dallas the risk he was taking if he
agrees to their contract is written if
he has any fine under the substance
abuse policy between now and september
of 2023 they can wipe out the guarantees
and they can cut him and those
guarantees save guys jobs all the time
ezekiel is still on the cowboys because
he's got a 12.4 million dollar fully
guaranteed salary this year if that
wasn't guaranteed he's gone it's over
it's done so gregory's protecting
himself and
peter shaffer who represents gregory
told me on the record that they gave the
cowboys a chance to remove that language
and do the same deal that the broncos do
and they declined so if they're mad at
anybody rich they need to be mad at
themselves
so what is the cowboys plan do you think
i mean
[Music]
you know they they kept tank lawrence
amari cooper's gone they signed gallup
cedric wilson is now a dolphin which i
think is a sneaky terrific signing by
miami and so um you know zeke's still
there pollard's still there they
franchise dalton schultz what do you
what do you think the plan is here with
the team you know on on a coach on and
everyone on
uh on a contract year what's dallas's
deal
well and it's funny you mentioned the
dolphins and cedric wilson i i don't
want to wake up to and on but i love the
teddy bridgewater signing it's a sneaky
under the radar
we could we could you know maybe teddy
can become the guy but we're not going
to advertise that
for fear of angering the the masses who
love tua but the cowboys already are
taking a look at von miller he's
available chandler jones is available
jadavian clown is available i mean when
he's healthy and it doesn't happen very
often he can be as dominant as anyone in
the nfl has ever been but you know we
see how important the pass rush is and
the cowboys prioritized keeping randy
gregory and the broncos had their
opportunity to snatch i mean look at the
afc west between the quarterbacks and
the pass rushers holy crap but the
cowboys had better find somebody and
there aren't a whole lot of options out
there and then uh a couple more minutes
left with mike florio here on the rich
eisen show the kyler murray um
situation his agent eric burkhart with
the jerry maguire-like treatise
uh dropped during combine week it's now
free agency week what's going on there
that's quiet you gave me the tip last
week that the cardinals images had been
restored to the kyler murray instagram
page and i poked around to see what
happened it was an olive branch and uh
kyle murray has been extending some
olive branches to the cardinals but they
are not yet extending the ultimate olive
branch to him which would be the
contract that he wants and if you look
at eric burkhart's twitter page you will
see that
that he
feels very strongly about what franchise
quarterbacks are worth and
you know a few years ago
whoever was up next for a new contract
at the quarterback position became the
highest paid quarterback in league
history it was just you work your way up
a little bit here a little bit here a
little bit there now there's a huge
range it's even bigger now than it was
the last time we talked about this you
got aaron rodgers that
new money average of 61.9 million which
is just mind-blowing and you've got matt
ryan at 30 million
that's 31 million between the number one
and number 10 highest paid quarterbacks
in the nfl where does kyler murray land
that is the crux of the problem between
the cardinals and murray murray's coming
in high cardinals coming in low and
we'll see if they can bridge that gap
and then last time we spoke we we had
the tb12 heat check segment that i had
just created the day before on the fly
on the show just like everything we do
here and so um you said uh
that you put the heat check on him
returning just at 11.99 right wasn't
that what it was brockman was it
seven nine nine seven you you let
yourself out of let me i don't know the
math what is zero zero three that's
three one thousand three one thousandths
of a percent that's where you're out and
then sure enough boom he's back so my
question for you is
is certainly since you were thinking
maybe the niners for him
uh what what about the idea that the
niners are just in on trey lance what
what what do you think
where where's all this stuff coming from
about the niners looking as you know a
hot minute they were interested in
watson yesterday and all that business
before it got refuted well i think the
reason why people wonder about trey
lance is there was kind of an
ambivalence last year about lance they
created an expectation that we're going
to see lance
more often and they they did that early
in the season and then they stopped and
we only saw him when jimmy g was injured
and there's that broader question of is
he reading at one point last year jed
york the owner of the team in an
interview with matt mayoko of nbc bay
area said and i'm paraphrasing here but
basically if we keep jimmy g for two
more years and make a 50 million dollar
investment and allowing trade lands to
develop then so be it so a lot of this
traces back to the 49ers trying to set
expectations a certain way and and maybe
they have and i'm not 100 convinced that
jimmy g even moves on i think he will i
think there'll be a market a trade
market for him once we find out what
happens with deshaun watson but yeah it
could be trey lance is the guy i mean
there was i think it was bet mgm had a
lot of action on trade lance for their
mvp prop at a pretty high you know
pretty high odds but they've come down
some uh with the uh the bets that were
placed on lance that's kind of a
surprise a first year starter uh but but
we've seen you know what look at the
past several years second year
quarterbacks
just come up out of nowhere
and become mpp candidates we saw it with
patrick mahomes in 2018 we saw with
lamar jackson in 2019 both won mvp
we saw kylie murray in 2020 have some
mvp buzz so you know it's not out of the
question that lance could take the
league by storm like some of these other
guys have yeah borrow made the super
bowl last year yeah you know
so you know and there's a second year
not first year starting but um
pretty much uh so before i let you go uh
what stories do you want to drop here
little nuggets little breadcrumbs from
playmakers to to let people know i know
obviously during the super bowl week you
you threw out some some deflategate uh
material um and some sean payton to the
cowboys material what do you want folks
to know well i don't know if we've
talked about this i don't think we have
and it kind of slipped through the
cracks sean payton spoke about this to
gq last month and we wrote something
about it on a friday afternoon
how close the saints came to drafting
patrick mahomes and how different the
world would be
if
mahomes was a saint
and it got so close and it was so
awkward because drew brees walked into
the draft room with friends
as the
picks were being made and as the saints
were moving in position to take mahomes
to the point where they had to go say
hey drew um there's a chance that uh
we're gonna be taking a quarterback here
just just so you're aware so they
avoided the aaron rodgers problem and uh
ultimately they didn't get
mahomes he went one pick earlier the
chiefs traded up but keep this in mind
and this is what's fascinating about the
saints interest in deshaun watson if
sean payton was still there
the saints would not be in on desean
watson they had their chance to get him
with pick number 11 in 2017 and they
didn't take him i think this is a
post-sean payton move if he was there
this would not be happening was that
they i remember that was in philadelphia
and and the saints traded up and we
thought like that's going we said it on
the air on the draft with mayok and
everybody sitting on the set this is
desean watson now right
and instead i believe it was marcus
davenport who they went for was that is
that what that was vladimor they weren't
they went up
they went up and they they they took
somebody other than
uh desean watson and we were all like
okay
and then obviously the texans went up
and got him and the dominoes have fallen
to the point where
we are right now
he would i'm not convinced peyton would
have taken my homes
mahomes had made it one more spot
because it and this is
this is an example of what happens and
we talk about this in playmakers the
smartest teams keep their mouth shut
because once it starts to trickle out
that's when the draft experts start to
hear and that's when guys get pumped up
because
nobody nobody had my homes as a top
quarterback nobody really knew who the
top quarterback was in 2017 it was all
very vague trubisky went first of all of
them but andy reid secretly loved
mahomes sean payton secretly loved
mahomes and another guy that i've heard
secretly love my homes mike mccarthy but
obviously he had aaron rodgers in green
bay that's right hey mike florio thanks
for the time congrats on the book look
for my call again
um you know and anytime if you ever want
me to be uh the away of the home and
home i'll i'll wake up early you know
all right it's very early i know it's
very early yeah
all right now i'll throw up he's writing
a check present rich is writing a check
no i'm future rich is not going to be
happy i don't know i mean
like i mean on the back end of the 5 a.m
pacific hour i'll do it i'm up anyway
i'm staring at the ceiling half the time
don't worry about it all right
take care of yourself okay man that's
mike florio present rich writing a check
future rich won't cash that's funny
playmakers where all books uh can be
acquired with mike florio how the nfl
really works and doesn't some great
information and fun stories in there hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here